[Musica]
vi parlerò questo pomeriggio di una
rivoluzione che parte dalla lettura e
potrebbe cambiare il mondo
quanto tempo è passato pochi secondi
pensate che in questi pochi secondi oggi
è possibile leggere tutte le lettere del
dna umano
per fare questo la prima volta ci sono
voluti quindici anni il dna umano è
qualcosa di immenso dobbiamo paragonare
a due hard disk un hard disk che
proviene dal padre è uno che proviene
dalla madre di queste hard disk sono
contenute tutte le informazioni che
consentono la nostra vita la nostra
manutenzione e le istruzioni sono così
raffinate che quando siamo una sola
cellula ci sono già le istruzioni per
farci diventare un individuo composto di
centinaia di miliardi di cellule
specializzate e coordinate che fanno sì
che noi viviamo per 70 o anche cento
anni
muovendoci pensando mangiando
seguendo questa relazione come state
facendo voi è qualcosa di incredibile
adesso vi parlo della lettura se
vogliamo paragonare il le istruzioni che
ci sono nel dna
dobbiamo immaginare
c'è questo potrebbe essere come le
istruzioni di che alla cellula istruisce
le altre su come montarsi quando queste
istruzioni sono sbagliate all'inizio poi
si procede male dopo il dna umano è
paragonabile ad un immensa biblioteca
una biblioteca enorme infinita questi
hard disk sono in ognuno dei centinaia
di miliardi di cellule quindi le
informazioni che noi continuiamo sono
incredibilmente vaste e questa
biblioteca per poter essere letta deve
essere letta con le tecnologie abbiamo
iniziato alcuni anni fa lettera per
lettera parola per parola come fanno i
bambini vanno imparano a leggere però
per leggere questa biblioteca si voleva
qualcosa di straordinario
una rivoluzione che cambiasse tutto
nella rivoluzione è avvenuto a pochi
anni fa la lettura parallela del dna
io vi spiego con un esempio in che cosa
consiste
anziché leggere libro per libro io rompo
tutti i libri prendo i fogli elis parco
tra di voi
ognuno legge una frase un pezzo una
pagina e poi invia un messaggio di
quello che ha letto io col computer
mette insieme tutto questo e riesco a
leggere velocemente tutto leggere
velocemente tutto perché questa cosa si
è moltiplicata poi per miliardi decine
di miliardi di unità di letture ed ecco
il la cosa impressionante che abbiamo
visto e cosa succede quando si legge
tutto il dna e non un singolo gene si
vedono delle cose che prima non si
potevano nemmeno immaginare innanzitutto
siamo tutti molto simili
però abbiamo quattro milioni di lettere
diverse l'uno dall'altro questo
indipendentemente dalla popolazione
dall'origine 4 milioni di differenze
alcune differenze sono più determinanti
di altre alcune sono più cruciali altre
meno alcune differenze fanno sì che noi
possiamo avere una malattia genetica
nuova e
la rivoluzione di questi anni sta in
questi numeri pensate che negli ultimi
sette anni sono state scoperte più
malattie genetiche nuove di quelle
conosciute nel tutto il resto della
storia dell'umanità e vedete che questa
malattia che c'è è una malattia in cui
c'è una sola lettera diversa che non è
né trasmessa dal padre né trasmessa
dalla madre molte di queste malattie non
si sospettava che fossero genetiche fino
a questa rivoluzione e sa che cosa è
legato questo è legato fondamentalmente
all'età del padre più anni al padre più
mutazioni dove avvengono nei figli dal
primo all'ultimo figlio ci sono sempre
più mutazioni ovviamente molte di questi
cambiamenti sono innocui come potete
immaginare altre causano una malattia
importante e questo esempio come si
procede nella genetica nel quando noi
vogliamo capire a quale luci sono
collegate le varie sezioni
dell'interruttore abbassiamo e alziamo
le levette e vediamo l'effetto che fa
questa cosa fatta su centinaia di
migliaia di individui e poi milioni di
individui ci permette di capire quali
sono i nostri circuiti dopo che abbiamo
letto c'è il passaggio successivo
imparare a leggere meglio il dna ci
permette di scrivere la scrittura ad
essere un fenomeno abbastanza lento
scriviamo come si scrive con una penna
stilografica facendo errori e sbavature
ma tra poco diventerà sempre più precisa
come una stampante laser che ci
permetterà di scrivere con precisione vi
propongo tre scenari il primo scenario
lo definirei restauro genetico una sola
mutazione che causa una malattia
genetica viene corretta riportando la
lettera come era prima non si tratta di
scrivere qualcosa di nuovo ma
semplicemente di rimettere le cose a
posto
questo scenario è più accettabile perché
si tratta di curare una malattia
una malattia grave però per questa cosa
abbiamo bisogno di correggere il difetto
il miliardi di cellule e quindi potrebbe
essere più conveniente correggere il
difetto quanto prima possibile riuscire
a correggere quando l'embrione non si è
ancora impiantato e quindi rendere un
bambino perfettamente sano e con figli
sani il secondo scenario è uno scenario
è uno scenario molto più ambizioso più
lontano nel tempo ma forse non così
lontano è quello di fare cambiamenti i
multipli del dna per metterlo in
sicurezza
metterlo in sicurezza significa
modificare tutti quei fattori di rischio
che ci rendono vulnerabili a malattie
infettive gravi a tumori a malattie
neurodegenerative a malattie
cardiovascolari questa cosa sarà un
salto irreversibile verso la
modificazione del genoma e porrò molti
problemi ci saranno governi che
bloccheranno questo tipo di ricerca
scientifica però prima o poi si farà
ci sarà sempre qualcuno qualche
movimento politico che sosterrà che
queste modificazioni del dna porteranno
ad una riduzione della spesa sanitaria a
una riduzione delle morti precoci a una
riduzione delle malattie invalidanti e
quindi se si può fare perché non farlo
perché far ammalare i nostri futuri
figli se questo si può evitare
a questo punto il terzo scenario ancora
più lontano nel futuro ancora più
ambizioso cioè quello di fare delle
modifiche del dna in positivo migliorare
le nostre capacità visive olfattive
migliorare la forza dei movimenti
migliorare il coordinamento l'umore il
benessere psicofisico e cosa più
ambiziosa di tutti
allungare la durata della vita
parafrasando rita levi montalcini si
tratterebbe di dare vita ai giorni e
giorni alla vita contemporaneamente
questo farebbe fare un salto epocale
alle generazioni
con i future perché permetterebbe un
dialogo fra persone che oggi sono
lontanissime nel tempo avere a
disposizione leonardo da vinci oggi
immaginiamo che cosa potrebbe
significare però questo pone anche degli
scenari inquietanti
lo scenario inquietante maggiore è che
alcuni pochi avrebbero accesso alle
modifiche genetiche ed altri sarebbero
completamente esclusi questa cosa e deve
far pensare deve far riflettere e noi
dobbiamo essere della partita di mettere
al centro sempre l'individuo rispettare
i diritti e la dignità dell'uomo e
questa la partita più importante che si
gioca dobbiamo pensare che il mondo come
lo stiamo costruendo pone degli
interrogativi molto più grossi e questo
è il significato più profondo della
biblioteca della vita grazie
[Applauso]